welcome back to another edition of the
gadget lab show i'm michael colauri and
i'm matt honan and matt's got something
funny on his wrist he's going to talk
about what is that thing peculiar i
believe is the word you're looking for
oh peculiar uh this is the basis it's a
activity monitor sort of uh we've seen a
lot of these it's sort of like the
fitbit or the why things we things
activity monitor they're they're the
there's the jawbone a ton of these on
the market right now this one looks just
like a watch this one is different yeah
and that it looks just like a watch now
is it a watch yes you can actually tell
the time with it set an alarm no no no
alarm okay sadly uh what you can do with
it though is monitor your sleep
monitor how many steps you're uh taking
a day and monitor your calories burn
because it doesn't just have the usual
mix of sensors in there like we've seen
on some of the others okay so most of
them use an accelerometer yeah right
like um you know the first iteration of
these devices that we saw they were
basically just you know fancy pedometers
right yeah pedometers with an app that's
what almost all of them are okay uh how
is this one different uh this one also
has sensors that take your skin
temperature
uh and that take that you can track your
blood flow so it's got an optical sensor
on the back side of this i'm gonna take
it off for just a moment
a little green light comes on and uh
what it's doing is it's using those uh
those measurements and others to get a
better idea of your physical activity
because sometimes you may be doing
something like say yoga or riding a
stationary bicycle
that isn't going to be tracked with an
accelerometer but your heart rate goes
up your body temperature goes up you
begin to perspire and it's and this can
pick that up so attract sweat
i don't know
can we perspiration
i've forgotten if it tracks sweat i
think it does okay
also it does have an accelerometer in it
as well right
it does have an accelerometer in it and
it does it does a pretty good job of
step counting uh i've done some
preliminary tests when i'm manually
counting steps and it's done it's done a
nice job on that without without having
to do any calibration um so the thing
that i've noticed in the in my testing
that i've done with these devices is
that the app experience kind of makes or
breaks
the tracking part so what is basis is
basis does not have an app which is
curious they do have an app they have an
app that's a desktop app a web app okay
and you can access it through your
phone's web interface but there's no
standalone
app there's no app that you can download
through the itunes store or through
you know android marketplace or anything
like that which is kind of cool because
it makes it device agnostic
it does but i also think there's a lot
to be said for having an app that can do
things like pick up data in the
background with this one you have to
sync it to your computer using a desktop
app and then it uploads it to the cloud
and then the phone looks in the cloud
exactly exactly so one of the things
that's nice on some of these newer
generation ones are they are the ones
that take advantage of bluetooth to send
data to your phone 24 7. uh just kind of
in the background so you don't ever have
to have that experience we take it off
and sync it okay the other thing that
people are doing is the data that it
collects and that it uploads into the
cloud
is that data can you pass that to other
apps through apis things like that not
currently not apparently so you can't
like share it with lose it or you know
your calorie tracker or whatever else
you're using not currently okay
uh how much does it run
this is a 200 uh device uh it's 1.99 you
can pre-order it right now on basis
they've they're they've got a back order
uh and oh so it's pretty popular it's
pretty popular there's actually been a
lot of buzz about this a lot of people
looking forward to it coming out uh and
so far i mean i haven't completed my
test but so far i really like it there's
there's some things that i'm not uh
crazy about
it's a little thick
but uh but you have to wear it to bed
you have to wear it to bed but it's not
it's it's it's not uncomfortable i've
worn some other
devices that uh
to bed that that i haven't been crazy
about my wife has not been crazy about
and
i won't ask right
this is this is you don't really notice
this you know i mean i i notice that if
i'm wearing a button-down shirt that i
have buttoned all the way down uh
that that's a little tight but otherwise
you know it's it's it's not bad to wear
to bed or where around the day okay well
that's cool comfortable enough
um you can read matt's full review of
the bassist band what's it called the
bassist watch the bassist band just
basically just basis you can read matt's
full review of the basis
on wired.com in the coming weeks
and that's all we have time for this
week so we'll be back next time with
more from gadget lab and until then
bye-bye